how it started and how it's going
infinite scroll in 2006 developer Azar
Ruskin introduced infinite scroll up
until this point the internet was a
collection of pages and you would have
to manually move to the next page to see
more content click click click this is
called pagination convenience but it was
possible to do it better especially for
mobile phones ours are made online
surfing simple content was created in
infinite scroll and then revealed at the
swipe of a finger now this algorithm is
used by all popular social network
insights but here we encounter a problem
endless scrolling is highly addictive
this phenomenon of the human Psych is
called units bias we feel uncomfortable
if we don't finish what we started but
infinite scroll cannot be finished and
when something bad happens in the news
for example The Thirst for information
grows alongside anxiety this is called
Doom scrolling oza Raskin regrets his
creation he couldn't have imagined his
negative implications so approach social
networks carefully and consciously and
look after yourself subscribe to learn
more about the online jungle